Speaker 1: All right, so there are some genuinely
interesting books that are just published
and forthcoming that are sort of telling the story
of a lot of the horrible behind the scenes things
that happened during the Trump administration.
We knew we expected we predicted it was widely
stated when the Trump administration was ending
that imagine all the things we learned during the
administration and now consider how much more we
are going to learn after the fact from reporting
and people that are willing to talk to reporters
about it. And we have two such stories today. One
is about Rudy Giuliani, which we will get to in a
moment, and it relates to the Big Lie about 2020.
But first, here is a story about Trump himself and
again, his completely authoritarian tendencies.
Trump said that whoever leaked the information
on his visit to the White House bunker when there
were protests going on in Washington, D.C.,
should be, quote, executed, executed by law
and order. No due process, no constitutional.
Absolutely not. Listen to this report from CNN.
Then President Donald Trump told a number of his
advisers in 2020 that whoever leaked information
about his stay in the White House bunker in
May of that year had committed treason and
should be executed. That means killed folks for
sharing details about the episode with members
of the press, according to excerpts of a new
book obtained by CNN from Wall Street Journal
reporter Michael Bender. Trump, along with then
first lady Melania Trump and their son Baron,
were all taken to the underground bunker for a
period of time during the protests. Spurred by the
police killing of Jorge Floyd, Trump boiled over
about the bunker story as soon as they arrived and
shouted at them to smoke out whoever had leaked
it. It was the most upset some aides had ever
seen. The president, whoever did that, they should
be charged with treason. They should be executed,
the book reads. Then White House Chief of
Staff Mark Meadows repeatedly tried to calm
the president down as startled aides avoided
eye contact. I'm on it. We're going to find
out who did it, Trump's top aide told his boss.
Trump remained angry over the leak for days,
repeatedly asked Meadows if he'd found the leaker
with his top aide becoming obsessed with finding
the source. According to the book, which noted
that those who said they'd heard the president
issued that warning had interpreted the outburst
as a sign of a president in panic. Now, of course,
Liz Harrington, Trump's chief spokeswoman,
has rejected the account in Bender's book,
saying that Trump never said this or
suggested it to anyone. So, again,
Trump says he's for law and order. Is that law
and order to smoke out and execute a leaker? No.
Trump says he's for due process. Is it due
process to do that? It is not. So the one
interesting thing is this is an admission
that the leaked information is true. Like
Trump wasn't saying, I'm furious that someone lied
about me going to the bunker. What the report is,
is that Trump is furious that information came
out about it. And remember that Donald Trump said
when he went to the bunker, it was for a
so-called inspection which never passed the
sniff test. But this was Trump on Fox News radio.
Speaker 6: And I said, go to the church. I didn't
know. Protesters are not. Nobody tells me that.
They say, yes, sir, we'll go to the church.
So we walked over. The church was very
fast. I think it was very symbolic.
I did hold up a Bible. I think that's a good
thing. Not a bad thing. And many religious
leaders loved it. Take a look at Franklin
Graham, so respected and so many others.
Take a look at Robert Jeffress. These are real
people. You know, they thought it was a great
symbol and I thought it was a great symbol.
Speaker 2: All right, Daniel, over to you.
Give us give us this.
Speaker 1: OK, and so as
as you as we. Oh, and then sorry. The actual part
about the the bunker as well. Let's get to that.
Here it is just cuing it up for everybody.
Mild technical difficulties
today, but we are getting to it.
And getting to it very strongly, I might
add, let's see here. OK, I believe we do have
Speaker 2: are engaging in Revett. Zionist history
Speaker 3: for many who look to Anderson
Cooper of CNN here, the Episcopal
bishop of Washington says she was
outraged that her church had been used as a
Speaker 1: prop. And this is liberty. Heat of the
Speaker 2: Year led to him going across the street
for this photo op. But here is what the president
said about his time in the bunker, please.
Speaker 6: It was a false report. I wasn't down.
I went down during the day and I was there for a
tiny little short period of time and was much more
for an inspection. There was a problem during
the day. These problems are during the night,
during the day. And I go down, gone down two
or three times, all for inspection. Right. And
you go there someday. You may need it, but you
go there. And I went down, I looked at it. It
was during the day. It was not a problem. And I
read about it like a big thing. There was never
Speaker 1: a regular old Kim Jong un, just
like Kim Jong un goes and inspects, you know,
places where corn is being grown and things like
that. Trump was just inspecting the bunker and
something he does regularly. Of course, his own
attorney general, William Barr, shortly thereafter
said, you know, Trump had to go to the bunker.
Speaker 3: Things were so bad that the Secret
Service recommended the president go down to the
bunker we had in our country. And so the decision
was made. We had to move the perimeter one block.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, of course, all of the stories
that Trump is telling are not true. But the big
news is Trump and his authoritarian tendencies. He
wanted the leaker executed. And it is just out of
this world stuff. And really, I mean, listen, you
know, I'm not I don't I don't want to rehabilitate
George W. Bush's image, but I don't think George
W. Bush was ever saying maybe we should have
someone who leaked something killed. Of course,
Barack Obama did not have those tendencies
either. This is really a unique to Trump thing.
So that's the new report with Trump. Let's now
talk about the new report about Rudy Giuliani.